well improving the mental and physical  well-being of kids during this pandemic  is the goal of a business owner here in  las vegas  jim katz is just one of the many gyms in  the valley that's been impacted by the  state's restrictions  however with the new increase in  capacity now to 35 percent they hope to  help get kids back into sports  we haven't had any spreading throughout  the gym which has been great  but people want their kids involved in  things that are active and social so  it's really hard to do that in a safe  way but we keep them distance they're  moving  it's a big space so we've been a place  that people really want to come back to  quickly rice added that with  competitions being virtual they are  hopeful  to resume regular competitions hopefully  in the very near future